hey mr greenwald did the checks come in
yet i don't think they're in yet can you
check with me later this afternoon hey
[ __ ] you better have my money when i
come for this [ __ ] like odb
to you all i want for my birthday is a
big booty hoe
but uh hey i know i love balloons
hey quentin can i borrow that pen
yeah take that
take that take that
take that i feel like you don't really
want to give it
it's not come on
so what's your type i ain't got no type
bad [ __ ] is the only thing that i
like
okay
cool
i'm sorry could you speak up i i can't
hear you oh uh well real g's move in
silence
like lasagna of course lasagna's silent
it's food
what was your ex like well he was this
dude named michael and he used to ride
motorcycles
dick bigger than a tower i was calling a
michael
i wish you did not tell me that
hey justin got a meeting in five
sorry i gotta miss call from your [ __ ]
as in my wife are you calling her right
now she called me tara
tara sorry zack she doesn't like it when
you scream you're talking to my wife
tell me when to go go tell me when to go
you're done tell me when to go right
this second tell me when it go i don't
know why you're not gone yet ooh
so you like bad [ __ ] i love bad
[ __ ] that's my [ __ ] problem
something wrong
i want to go home
i'm a boss i call the shots